hello everyone is welcome to
our room in our press room
I am delighted to have with me
our negotiator michel barnier who will
present to you the agreement reached this morning
a lot or a young man drafted six
openings at d'  elsewhere had 17 from rock
city the school of persons are curved
match there gentlemen i made you
wait a few
more minutes than the
scheduled time because i wanted the
legal text in question to
be published it comes from the  to be
on our side it is therefore at your
disposal from now on
so we have reached an agreement with the
British government on the
orderly withdrawal of the United Kingdom from the
European Union and also on the framework of
our future relationship
it is the result of  intensive work
by the two teams of negotiators, whom I
would personally like to thank,
of course, the British team and our own team for
their tenacity and their
professionalism,
but also the result on the European side
of an ongoing dialogue of real
trust built up throughout these
three years with the 27 member states
with the European parliament since we
have I can tell you but you
know it really co-constructed
our positions on our side and this new agreement
this agreement is approved at the level of the
negotiators with the present juncker who
has  concluded this morning with the first
johnson we will present it
shortly to the european council at 27
i would also like to
personally thank president donald for his confidence
throughout these three years
for all that has already had advice and
all  his team
this text had gentlemen allows
to bring legal security of
certainty everywhere where the bric sites
created as any separation of
uncertainty and in particular is
first for citizens for
european citizens
in the united kingdom  British citizens
who live in one of our member states
these citizens have always
been and will remain our priority those
of the member states and I want to say it
also that of the european parliament
the uncertainty for its citizens has
lasted too long
thanks to this agreement their rights will be
finally guaranteed in the long term certainty
also for the initiators of
countless projects financed by the budget of
the european union in the 27
member states and in the united kingdom since thanks
to this agreement the financial commitments
already made at 28 will be well respected and
honored at 28  certainty also for them
all the people the companies
concerned by all the other subjects of
the separation
I told you here for my very first
press briefing three years ago that the
social human
legal economic technical
financial consequences were innumerable for
all these people and these  companies
concerned by all the other subjects there will
now be more certainty
I am thinking of euratom I am thinking of the
protection of
existing intellectual property rights the protection
of geographical indications the
protection of personal data
finally this proposal also includes
the transition period  which had been
requested by the British government
and which will last until the end of
2020 fourteen months now 14 months and
perhaps a year or two
more if there is a joint agreement between the
United Kingdom and the  the european union
ladies and gentlemen of yuki government
has want it hot and one foot in the wild
roses agreements which hang from the creation
of protocols in island and orson suazo
say they negotiate something 18 years of uk or
la fouly committed to protect pis to
protect stability  de highland variant
we had to resign all objective frost
include operative liguria solutions in
the wind that would void to border
between hay nahda north hoenheim reserve
de hollande economy and protect
integrity of the single market second
bed and pontics stream l'importante or
prime minister johnson  and the uk on
dates new sound remains in the uk 14
territory discussions over passes
timelines difficulties and we have
deliverers in we have delivered to gather
the solution date refund stay in
human form she loved this dwarf one north
island will remain aligned de  limits
this offer yules notably
death metal band policy applicable to
procedures good will take place de paul
ce off entry into piece i'm not a
cross de fortis by all uk authorities
will be in charge of planning de l'union
kastens god in person  i'm not to be used
applied bull precise solving
of equations of castan duties norstein
will remain in de 4.2 uk carstens
territory it will there for benefit for
uk future very polished
in his judgment returned a smile to a
report into a  single man so what have i
done to skweres lice sur que uk
authorities canap laï yu qataris product
as a form certainly built according to
the NGO avaaz goods international and are
not at risk up between ring housing market
however for good at risk 23.6 market  uk
authorities yes the range of 'news tariffs
of free mind is money piece we are
working on it shoe of life and y said
anywhere objects void distortion
out of competition within the seeker
market for good on dispose
also or managed watch is to objective
maintain the integrity of single market
the bull satisfy 15
religious legitimacy a van ryn must near minister
johnson 1 of tee shot wanted to ensure
long democratic supports should
apply on the bench uk authorities
have our and sales
a room is not for use in false trees
or protocols of
representative voters like north island will
be able to decide by simpore majority
whether to continue after a maul advance
a road in northern islands to the notes
say democratic supporter is
cornerstone to the wind or binds us to grid
to the relatives
why cause me ten feeds  hagrid
protocol is no length he is approved
between said young uk saw 6 years
twin day consult ladies and gentlemen
obviously wendy this national cast and
we talk about the economy beats technical
matters beat goods beaters the enemy
it's true franck the dates ants
since i once in three years was really
matters à deux pipes of the people of
national d' adam and what really matters
auspices ladies and gentlemen
finally beyond this separation and
the withdrawal agreement we have reached an
agreement and it is for  me at least as
important to revise the
political declaration which will have to be adopted by the
European Council and by the Parliament and
which will be the case within the rather
specific framework of the negotiation of the
negotiations which will now
open to build rebuild future
ambitious partnerships with  the
united kingdom friendly countries partner countries
allied countries on this point the government
of boris johnson has made a clear choice
in terms of the future economic relationship
it is the choice of a
free trade agreement any reference to other
options, in particular the option of
possibly creating a single customs territory between us,
has therefore been eliminated.
What does not change, however, is if
I may say so, our
fairly lasting geographical proximity is also
our interdependence with the economy of the
United Kingdom.  very strong we have
agreed to have
level playing field id guarantees in order to
allow an ambitious free trade agreement
that means without tariffs and
without quotas on this point I can
testify I want to testify for
having often spoken about it in  my various
visits within the union that the
member states all the member states the
european parliament and the
national parliaments obviously the businesses the
business communities that I have
met are extremely attentive and
will remain extremely attentive to
the existence  a common base on the
standards applicable at the end of the
transition
with regard to social rights
environmental protection
state aid and tax issues
in total the level of ambition of our
future agreement  free trade will be well
proportional to the level and the quality
of the rules of the economic game between us
between the european union and the
united kingdom you have received here is the agreement that
we concluded at the end of these
very intense days and even these
nights of  negotiations the legal text
is now available I
wish you a good reading
on this basis the assessment that we
will present shortly with the
prion heart to the European Council and that
we have obtained together a
fair and reasonable result which corresponds to
our principles
on the European side it is
now up to the European Council
to assess the content of this agreement
and then, if it wishes, the Council
to approve it, just like the
European Parliament, which I want to thank for its
confidence and which will have the last  word
we are going to continue this process
today do not have many days
in dialogue and respect for
our institutions
I want to say in conclusion that we
have and this has been the object of my work
and of the mission  for three years
now a fair and reasonable basis
make a noise do not scramble for an
orderly withdrawal from the united kingdom which is
much better than a disorderly withdrawal
and if I may say above all to
start to start we
want it as soon as possible from
november 1 to  work on a new
partnership with the united kingdom
thank you for your attention
thank you